Welcome to the Deep Dive, where
we dig into complex topics and
hopefully pull out the real gems
of understanding for you.
That's the plan.
So today we're tackling a
question that might just well
flip your perspective on funding
big social programs entirely.
What if the answer to funding
these really ambitious goals,
you know, like universal
healthcare, free college, truly
robust social safety Nets?
What if the answer was something
everyone seems to love to hate?
Something that definitely gets a
bad rap.
Exactly something that
consistently gets pushed aside
in our public discourse.
Right.
And our mission in this deep
dive is to explore a, well, a
truly provocative argument.
It's about the unexpected,
almost counterintuitive role of
tariffs, Yes, tariffs, in
potentially achieving what some
might envision as a, let's say,
comprehensive socialist utopia
right here in America.
Tariffs.
OK, definitely not the first
thing that springs to mind for
funding social programs.
Not at all, and we're diving
deep into excerpts from an
essay.
It's titled If American
Socialists Were Real, They'd
Love Terrace dot PDF by Chris
Abraham, and the central premise
Abraham presents is quite bold.
He basically contends that if
American socialists were
genuinely serious about hitting
their stated goals.
You mean the big ones?
Healthcare Education.
Precisely.
Then they should be advocating
for tariffs, like really pushing
for them as the primary funding
mechanism for all these desired
social services that they
aren't.
But as he points out, they are
conspicuously not.
It's a real disconnect he's
highlighting.
Interesting.
So for you, our listener, this
deep dive is going to be, I
think, an illuminating journey
will meticulously unpack why
Abraham presents tariffs as what
he actually calls the only path
to achieving these really
ambitious social goals.
The only path.
It's strong language.
It is, and we'll challenge some
very common perceptions you
might hold about tariffs, you
know, who really pays for them,
what are the broader economic
implications, that whole debate.
Yeah, the standard narrative
versus what Abraham's putting
forward.
Exactly.
By the end of this conversation,
you'll undoubtedly have a
uniquely informed perspective on
a highly debated topic.
It might even prompt you to
rethink some of your own
assumptions about, well, how we
pay for the kind of society we
collectively say we desire.
It's a fascinating thought
experiment, really, but he
grounds it in a very direct
argument.
Definitely.
So let's let's begin to unpack
this.
OK, so let's unpack this vision
first, as it's described in
Abraham's essay, This American
Socialist Utopia, it's truly
comprehensive.
I mean, it seems to touch on
almost every facet of life that
a citizen might interact with.
It's not just one or two things.
No, exactly.
We're talking about aspirations
like free healthcare, free
college, subsidized childcare,
maternity leave, maternity
leave, housing programs, mental
health clinics, public
broadcasting, university
personal services of any kind.
It's an expansive list, really
almost all-encompassing.
It implies a pretty profound
societal overhaul for many
people.
Absolutely.
But then, inevitably, comes the
crucial question, the one that
always emerges right at the
forefront of any such ambitious
proposal.
Yeah, the practical bit.
The fundamental logistical one,
Yeah.
How do you actually pay for all
of it?
You know, when you dare to dream
big about a better world, you
also have to grapple with the
very real, very tangible
mechanics of making that world
economically sustainable.
Making it possible.
Right.
This isn't just about like
wishing for a more equitable
society, it's about devising the
concrete pathways to actually
fund such an ambitious
undertaking.
And what's truly fascinating
here and really central to
Abraham's whole argument is his
assertion that the traditional
ways, you know, high tax rates
like those eye watering 80
percent top marginal rates we
saw in the US back in the 1950s.
Right, the post war era.
Exactly, he argues, those are
simply no longer effective for
funding these kinds of ambitious
programs in our, well,
profoundly modern, globalized
economy.
Why?
Not what's changed so
drastically.
Well, he introduces what he
vividly calls the ghost problem.
The ghost problem.
OK.
Yeah, and it's quite a
compelling metaphor, I think,
for the challenges of trying to
tax wealth today.
In today's interconnected world,
he argues, wealthy individuals
in these massive multinational
corporations have this, well,
unparalleled ability to, as
Abraham colorfully puts it,
teleport their money across
borders.
Teleport.
OK, Not literally I assume.
No, no, not literally, but it
speaks to the speed and the
ease.
You know capital can just vanish
from 1 jurisdiction and reappear
in another almost instantly.
So what are we talking about?
Like complex accounting tricks.
Exactly.
Sophisticated financial
engineering.
Establishing complex offshore
holding companies.
Strategically transferring
intellectual property rights to
low tax places like Ireland or
somewhere.
Like we hear about with big tech
companies sometimes.
Precisely, Or even just using
high frequency trading platforms
that can shift vast sums across
continents in milliseconds, they
can quite legally and
efficiently just change their
legal address to Dublin or
Luxembourg or you know, whatever
offers the most favorable tax
environment.
Making their wealth effectively
invisible, or at least
untouchable to a single
country's tax system.
That's the idea.
It becomes elusive.
And the core of this contention
is quite stark, really, and
uncompromising.
Abraham declares you can't tax
ghosts, and billionaires have
already figured out how to
become ghosts, so chasing them
is futile.
Futile.
Wow, that's a strong word.
It is, And he contrasts this
sharply with the economic
realities back in the 1950s.
You know, back then, when those
extremely high domestic tax
rates were in place, the wealthy
couldn't just hop on a private
to Monaco at a moment's notice
with all their financial
records.
Right.
Or move millions with a few
clicks.
Exactly.
Nor could they move their
immense wealth with a few mere
keystrokes from a laptop.
The physical infrastructure, the
digital infrastructure for that
kind of global financial
fluidity just didn't exist like
it does now.
So trying to bring back those
80% rates today.
Abraham views any attempt to re
implement such high domestic tax
rates today as fundamentally
quixotic, like chasing
windmills, a pursuit of an ever
elusive target that will always
remain just out of reach.
Leaving those ambitious social
programs perpetually
underfunded.
And leaving the people who
advocate for them perpetually
frustrated.
That's his take.
OK, so if traditional taxation
is basically chasing these
financial ghosts through this
increasingly complex globalized
maze, what does Abraham propose
as the well, the concrete
unavoidable solution?
His answer is tariffs.
Tariffs back to Paris.
Back to tariffs.
And this is where the argument
really starts to, you know,
challenge conventional wisdom
because tariffs are presented as
the unavoidable answer, the
mechanism that bypasses all
those modern financial loopholes
that make wealth so incredibly
mobile today.
So how are they different?
Abraham highlights how tariffs
are fundamentally different
from, say, income or corporate
taxes precisely because, as he
puts it, they collect at the
border.
OK, a physical point.
A physical point of collection.
It literally cannot be moved
offshore or it's geographically
anchored.
They don't care about your tax
lawyer or your offshore shell
companies, Abraham asserts.
It just cuts through all those
layers of financial
sophistication.
It sounds almost simple.
The simplicity of it, as he
describes it, is quite striking.
You want to sell in the biggest
market in the world, You pay.
End of story.
No way around it if you want
access to US consumers.
That's the argument.
There's no complex accounting to
evade them, no legal acrobatics
needed to avoid them.
If you want access to the
American consumer base, the cost
is clear and it's collected
right at entry.
And the revenue generated, where
does that go?
According to Abraham, it flows
straight into the state's
coffers.
It's direct, it's immediate.
And crucially, he argues, it
doesn't bleed the middle class
dry.
How does he figure that?
Because that's the usual
argument against tariffs, right?
That they hurt regular people.
Right, but his point is that
because the tax isn't directly
levied on domestic income or
consumption in the same way, say
income tax or sales taxes, the
argument is that it falls
primarily on the importer.
The company bringing the goods
in.
Yes.
And potentially, as we'll
definitely get into on corporate
profit margins, this also means
it doesn't need to chase the
rich because the wealth is
collected at the point of entry
of goods, not by trying to track
down individual or corporate
income that, as we said, can be
hidden or moved.
So he sees it as cleaner,
simpler.
He describes the system as clean
and simple, suggesting it's a
direct, efficient and
surprisingly unburdened way to
generate the massive, stable
revenue required for
comprehensive social services.
It's sort of sidesteps all the
complexities and perceived
failures of modern taxation
entirely.
OK, now here's where Abraham's
argument gets really
interesting, I think, and quite
provocative because he tackles
head on that common narrative
surrounding tariffs.
The one we hear all the time.
Yeah, he points out that the
media can only talk about
tariffs as if they're the end of
the world, constantly screaming
that familiar refrain.
Tariffs are attacks on consumer.
Right.
Makes everything more expensive
for the average person.
That is, of course, the
widespread belief, isn't it?
The tariff just hike prices on
everything you buy, hitting your
wallet directly.
But Abraham pushes back hard on
this, well, this oversimplified
view.
He suggests it's maybe a
narrative perpetuated without a
full understanding, or maybe
even without a Full disclosure
of the complex economic
realities actually at play.
Implying it serves certain
interests maybe, rather than
presenting the whole picture.
And Abraham doesn't actually
outright deny the basic truth of
the media's claim.
He acknowledges that, well, yes,
tariffs are technically a tax on
imports.
That's just factual.
And he concedes that they
certainly hit the wholesalers
and the importers first, right
there at the border.
Some of that cost absolutely can
be passed on to consumers.
That's a partial truth, an
undeniable economic mechanism.
But here's the part Abraham
claims nobody bothers to say.
And it's a really crucial
counterpoint to the prevailing
narrative.
Companies also eat it.
Their profit margins take the
hit.
OK, So it's not just consumers
paying?
That's his core assertion here.
It's a significant 1.
He isn't just talking about some
minor adjustment, he's implying
A fundamental shift in where the
actual burden lands.
Does he give examples?
He points to very specific
examples asserting that the
endless 400% markups on Chinese
junk gone. 400% markups.
Wow.
Think about the current business
model for a lot of importers,
right?
They source incredibly cheap
goods from overseas, often from
countries with lower labor
costs, maybe less stringent
environmental rules than they
sell them in Western markets
with these enormous markups.
Which generates huge profits.
Huge profits which ultimately
benefit shareholders.
Abraham argues that tariffs bite
directly into these sacred
shareholder returns.
Suddenly the people who have
been profiting off your
consumption for decades by
importing these cheap goods at
massive markups, they have to
bleed a little.
As he puts it, they lose some of
their inflated margins.
So this wood forest them to
either absorb the cost.
Or reduce their profit
expectations.
Or maybe find more efficient,
perhaps even domestic supply
chains, which is another part of
his argument we'll get to.
And his reaction to the
shareholder complaints?
His dismissal of the common
outcry from shareholders is
quite provocative.
He just states, Oh no, the
shareholders cry good, cry
harder.
OK, so that's pretty blunt.
Yeah, it's not just an economic
argument at this point.
It's a very direct, almost a
moral challenge to the current
system.
He's suggesting that excessive
corporate profit has been built
on the back of these cheap
imports, and tariffs serve as a
necessary rebalancing agent.
Forcing a redistribution of the
economic impact, moving it away
from just the consumer, or at
least sharing that impact more
directly with corporate profits
and shareholder returns.
Exactly, that's the crux of his
counter narrative.
So given Abraham's argument for
tariffs as this viable, maybe
even necessary funding
mechanism, one that he says
primarily hits corporate
profits, not just consumers, he
then raises a really pointed
critique.
Why aren't American socialists
the very people who ostensibly
desire these vast social
programs?
Why aren't they embracing
tariffs?
Yeah, if it's the solution, why
the resistance?
Exactly.
This is where Abraham introduces
this idea of performance versus
genuine commitment.
He claims, First off, that the
very word tariff has been
poisoned by politics.
By the political dimension,
right.
Particularly due to its strong
association with figures like
Donald Trump, it's become so
ideologically charged that for
many people, it's just instantly
dismissed, regardless of its
potential economic or societal
merits.
It becomes an automatic
rejection based on partisan
affiliation.
Almost.
That's what he seems to suggest.
But beyond just that political
poisoning, Abraham goes deeper.
He delves into what he sees as a
fundamental contradiction in the
desires of many who claim to
want this socialist utopia.
OK, he argues, that most people
don't actually want the
socialist utopia they claim to
want.
They want to want.
It they want to want it, what
does that mean?
It means, he suggests, they like
the feeling of wanting it, of
caring, of being on the good
team.
It implies this significant
disconnect between the
aspiration and the actual
willingness to make genuine
sacrifices or accept
uncomfortable trade-offs.
Because those trade-offs might
be.
Well, because simultaneously,
people also profoundly like,
they're cheap Amazon crap.
They're $99 homage watches,
they're fast fashion, they're
three-year car leases.
The stuff tariffs might make
more expensive.
Precisely.
And also things like their 401
KS, their stock portfolios and
their ever growing personal
investments.
So personal wealths tied into
the current system.
Exactly.
You know 401K stock portfolios.
These are personal retirement
and investment assets, right?
They often benefit directly from
the existing globalized economic
model that delivers those cheap
goods and consequently high
corporate profits, which boost
stock values.
So there's a deep ingrained
attachment to the current
consumer driven economy and the
personal wealth and convenience
it enables.
Right.
So what does this all mean
according to Abraham?
He suggests this fundamental
contradiction is at play, a
preference for the performance
of caring without the pain of
actually changing anything.
Ouch, that's a sharp critique.
It is.
It's about wanting the perceived
moral high ground of advocating
for social programs, but without
being willing to endure the real
World Economic adjustments that
might be necessary to fund them.
Specifically, adjustments that
impact personal consumption
habits or maybe even those
investment portfolios.
So it's an uncomfortable
observation, perhaps, about the
gap between our rhetoric and the
tangible realities of policy
implementation.
That's exactly how he frames it,
a gap between wanting the
outcome and accepting the means.
OK.
So if we connect this argument
now to the bigger picture,
Abraham brings in this really
fascinating and I think pivotal
concept from someone named Mark
Wayne Harrison.
Mark Wayne Harrison, OK.
Yes, and Abraham even has this
little aside joking about
Harrison's middle name and his
playful aversion to it.
But the point Harrison makes,
which Abraham leans on super
heavily, is profound.
Harrison states that you can
innovate energy to near 0 cost,
but you can't innovate
materials.
Energy versus materials.
OK, explain that distinction.
This distinction is critical,
really, to understanding
Abraham's full argument for why
tariffs aren't just a funding
mechanism, but maybe a necessary
systemic adjustment.
Right?
So when we talk about energy,
Abraham explains this through
Harrison's lens, right?
Energy can be scaled, hacked,
solared, winded, naked into
abundance.
We see that happening, right?
Solar getting cheaper, wind
turbines getting bigger.
Exactly.
We've seen incredible
advancements in renewable energy
tech, solar panels becoming
exponentially more efficient and
cheaper, wind turbines reaching
massive scales, and, you know,
the long term potential of
advanced nuclear power.
The conceptual possibility for
virtually limitless cheap energy
seems potentially within our
grasp, at least from a
theoretical standpoint, through
technological innovation.
OK.
So energy can be innovative,
potentially to abundance.
What about materials?
Materials.
That's the completely different
story.
And this is where Abraham
introduces a pretty sobering
reality check.
Materials have to be mined,
refined, processed.
They're finite.
Finite, unlike energy from the
sun or wind.
Precisely unlike energy, which
can be harnessed from flow
resources, sun, wind or
transformed like nuclear fission
materials are stock resources.
They are literally embedded in
the Earth's crust.
You have to dig them up.
The act of extraction itself is
energy intensive as
environmental costs.
Abraham uses this striking
analogy to drive this home.
We're ants crawling on the
surface of a giant asteroid
called.
Earth, that's a vivid image,
emphasizes our limited resource.
Base it really does and the idea
of solving this problem by you
know, going off world asteroid
mining, Mars mining.
They buy solutions.
He quickly dismisses those as
absurd.
He argues the cost would be
The resources required to make
it feasible would dwarf anything
we'd gain.
So we're stuck with what we have
here.
The core message is clear and
unequivocal.
Earth is it.
Earth is the mine.
And while sure, we haven't
exhausted all resources yet,
every extraction has a cost, not
just economic but environmental,
and in terms of sheer material
availability and the increasing
difficulty of accessing the
reserves that are left.
This underlying reality of
finite materials.
For Abraham, it's a fundamental
constraint that our current
economic models, especially
those driven by assumptions of
infinite growth and infinite
consumption, simply fail to
adequately address.
And building on that really
profound point about the finite
nature of materials, Abraham
then drives home the
unsustainability of infinite
consumption.
He connected directly to our
modern consumer habits.
How so?
He uses another insightful
example from Mark Harrison.
Harrison apparently half
jokingly suggested that if
energy became truly free, like 0
cost right, we could just build
cheap Tyvek houses for everyone
and crank the HVAC year round.
You know, enjoy perpetual
comfort.
Sounds nice, if a bit wasteful.
Maybe a comfortable dream?
It does sound like a fantastic,
futuristic, comfortable dream,
doesn't it?
But then comes the critical
question, the one designed to
puncture that illusion of
limitless material abundance.
OK, what's the catch?
The question is, where do the 9
billion HVAC units come from?
Where does the copper, the
steel, the plastics, the
refrigerants, the infrastructure
for a global grid come from?
The physical stuff.
Exactly this illustrates the
core dilemma.
Even if energy became
effectively free, the physical
components required for
universal comfort, for
widespread technological
advancement, for a truly global
standard of living, they still
fundamentally rely on finite
physical material resources.
You can't just 3D print more
copper out of thin air.
You can't just print more copper
or manufacture more rare earth
elements.
Abraham's conclusion from this
is stark and he argues
undeniable.
Energy can be free, but
materials never will be.
That's the heart of it.
You can't have infinite
consumption.
Exactly this directly challenges
the very foundation of the
current economic paradigm, which
often implicitly assumes endless
growth and endless resource
availability for an ever growing
global population with ever
increasing consumption demands.
And he links this to specific
things.
Yeah, Abraham points to very
specific, relatable examples of
this infinite crap, as he calls
it, that we're just inundated
with infinite T, new orders,
infinite Aliexpress trinkets,
infinite Sheen, fast fashion.
Things designed to be cheap and
disposable.
Precisely products designed to
be cheap, disposable, and
constantly replaced, fueling
this relentless cycle of
consumption that, according to
Abraham, is fundamentally
unsustainable.
Is that the basic math of finite
materials just?
Doesn't work in the long run.
It's a powerful argument against
the current global supply chain
model, isn't it?
The one that prioritizes rock
bottom costs and high volume
over durability, Quality, maybe
long term sustainability.
Absolutely highlighting how our
addiction to cheap, disposable
goods is in direct, unavoidable
conflict with the planet's
material limits.
And this is precisely where
tariffs come back into play.
Within Abraham's larger
framework, they serve as what he
describes as a necessary break
on this well, this insanity of
infinite a break.
OK, the argument is that Terrace
don't just generate revenue for
the state.
They fundamentally alter
consumer behavior and market
dynamics in a way that he argues
aligns with the reality of
finite materials.
How do they work as a break
specifically?
Well, by making imported goods
more expensive because, as
Abraham argues, those increased
costs bite into corporate profit
margins, which in turn might
necessitate some increase in
consumer price or at least a re
evaluation of product sourcing.
They make you think twice before
buying another piece of
disposable junk.
So it's not just about
collecting duties.
No, it's about discouraging that
culture of disposability,
planned obsolescence, the
endless acquisition of low
quality fleeting trends.
And beyond just slowing
consumption.
Tariffs, according to Abraham,
also make domestic products
competitive.
Again, the protectionist angle.
Right.
If imported goods, particularly
the cheap ones, become more
expensive due to tariffs, then
locally manufactured structured
alternatives become
comparatively more attractive,
more economically viable.
Which could mean jobs.
Exactly.
This fosters the revitalization
of local industries and creates
domestic jobs that were often
outsourced precisely to achieve
those lower production costs
overseas.
This, in turn, Abraham suggests,
encourages quality.
How does encourage quality?
Well, the idea is when domestic
producers are competing in a
market where super cheap imports
are less dominant, they can
focus on creating more durable,
higher value products.
They can differentiate
themselves not just on rock
bottom price, but on longevity,
on craftsmanship.
Which would then discourage the
landfill culture.
Exactly.
It naturally discourages
landfill culture by making
cheap, throwaway items less
appealing and maybe
incentivizing consumers to
invest in goods that actually
last longer.
And it still funds the state.
And most importantly for the
core argument of funding social
services, they fund the state
without touching your paycheck.
This circles back to that
earlier point about tariffs
being a clean and simple revenue
stream, one that avoids the
pitfalls of directly taxing
individuals or corporations that
can easily move their wealth.
So Terrace become this
multifaceted solution, in his
view, addressing material
limits, promoting sustainable
consumption, supporting domestic
industries, and funding social
programs all at once.
That's the comprehensive picture
he paints.
Abraham then tries to illustrate
this point further right.
He shares a personal anecdote
from his time living in Germany,
an observation that really tries
to bring this tariff model to
life for you.
Our listener offers a real world
example, maybe of how these
principles can play out in a
developed economy.
Yeah, his experience there.
He observes something quite
distinct, he says.
Food dirt cheap and locally
sourced.
Delicious.
OK, so good affordable local
food.
Which strongly suggests a robust
domestic agricultural sector,
probably protected and
prioritized through policy,
right?
But then comes the striking
contrast.
But everything else, Furniture,
electronics, clothes, was
expensive.
So not everything was cheap.
No, and this isn't just
presented as a casual
observation.
It's framed as a direct,
tangible consequence of the
economic policies they had in
place.
And why was that the case,
According to him?
Abraham explains because of
tariffs, because of VAT, because
imports were a free for all.
VAT remind us what that is
right?
VAT is value added tax.
It's a consumption tax common in
Europe, levied at each stage of
production and distribution.
So it's not just import duties
hitting at the border, but a
broader tax on consumption that
also discourages disposable
goods throughout the chain.
So a deliberate policy choice
then, to protect their domestic
markets from a flood of cheap
foreign stuff?
That's how he presents it, and
it aligns it's perfectly with
his argument about slowing the
turn of materials.
And this protection, according
to Abraham, is precisely how
they fund their services.
That's how they keep domestic
industries alive.
It's a strategic, integrated
approach he's describing.
Exactly.
Germany, Abraham argues, doesn't
want wash back.
They want to sell Mercedes and
BMW's to the world, not absorb
an endless flood of cheap goods.
Right.
Export high value stuff, manage
the import.
Precisely, they prioritize
exporting high value
manufactured goods that command
premium prices globally while
carefully managing imports to
protect their internal market
and implicitly, their resource
base.
And he sees this elsewhere, too.
Yeah, he extends this
observation to other
sophisticated European nations,
stating same with Italy, with
France.
They sell wine, cheese,
Ferraris, olive oil, and they
protect their markets.
They export value.
They don't import junk.
And the crucial link back to the
main topic.
He makes it explicit, and the
revenue from those protective
measures underwrites the social
services Americans claim to
admire.
He's suggesting a direct
correlation between these
protectionist trade policies,
tariffs, consumption taxes like
VAT, and the successful funding
of comprehensive social safety
Nets and a higher quality of
domestic production.
But as Abraham points out, here
in the US, the conversation
often just stops.
It dies.
Yeah.
Why?
He argues it's because a
particular political figure,
Trump, said the word tariff 1st
and for half the country that
means it's evil.
Back to the political.
Poison.
Exactly.
It's presented as the
significant, almost
insurmountable political hurdle,
a chilling effect on rational
discourse that prevents A
genuine examination of the
policies actual merits.
He has a name for this, right?
Yeah, Abraham labels this
phenomenon.
The original Trump Derangement
Syndrome defined it basically as
if he's for it, you must be
against it.
Even if it might achieve your
goals.
Even if it's the only thing that
could make your dreams come
true.
Now, just to be clear, this
isn't us endorsing that term or
any political figure.
No, of course not.
We're reporting Abraham's
observation.
Right.
It's Abraham's keen observation
of how partisan association with
a policy can, in his view,
automatically disqualify it for
many people, regardless of its
inherent efficacy or its
potential to achieve those
stated social goals.
See becomes less about its
economic impact and more about
like tribal political identity.
That's the dynamic he's
describing.
And Abraham then presents this
really stark choice that he
believes many people are making,
maybe unconsciously, perhaps
partly due to this political
poisoning.
What's the choice?
He claims that people choose
their cheap fast fashion over
their free healthcare.
They choose their disposable
culture over universal college.
They choose to protect their
portfolios instead of actually
funding the services they say
they care about.
Wow, that's a very direct
accusation.
Extremely direct, he's saying
that the perceived convenience
and the immediate gratification
of cheap consumer goods, along
with, you know, safeguarding
personal financial investments
that often thrive in the current
globalized system.
These things are implicitly
prioritized over the long term
structural changes required to
fund comprehensive social
services.
Implying a deep seated
resistance to discomfort or
change.
Even when that change might lead
directly to the very societal
benefits that are loudly
advocated for.
So the political landscape
poisoned by these partisan
associations becomes, in his
view, the ultimate barrier to
implementing what he sees as the
only viable funding mechanism
for a genuinely progressive
social agenda.
OK, so let's be absolutely clear
here.
Abraham's not suggesting that
tariffs are some kind of magic
bullet, right?
No consequences that they'll
make this pursuit of a socialist
society totally painless.
No, not at all.
Quite the contrary, he's very
upfront about the unavoidable
sacrifices that would inevitably
come with such a policy shift.
How so?
Tariffs won't make socialism
painless, he states directly.
And you as the consumer would
definitely feel it in your daily
life.
Prices will rise, he
acknowledges without any
equivocation.
So that cheap Amazon stuff, the
fast fashion.
That incredibly cheap Amazon
trinket or the latest fast
fashion outfit you're maybe
accustomed to buying on a whim?
That easy, constant acquisition
of new disposable items would
likely largely disappear or
become significantly more
expensive, Abraham notes.
Very pointedly, you won't be
able to fill your house with
disposable junk.
That's a direct tangible trade
off then a higher cost for
consumer goods, less cheap
stuff.
A.
Reduction in the sheer volume of
cheap material possessions?
Yes, in exchange for something
else, namely comprehensive
social services.
It's a candid admission that the
pathway to this socialist
utopia, as he calls it, isn't
some kind of free lunch.
Not at all.
It's presented as a fundamental
reprioritization of societal
spending and individual
consumption habits.
It requires A willingness to
actively give up certain current
conveniences and immediate
gratifications for broader long
term societal benefits.
It really forces a choice.
OK, but in exchange for those
very real sacrifices, Abraham
clearly reiterates the promised
benefits he believes tariffs
would unequivocally deliver.
Right.
The upside, he argues simply.
You'll have services.
You'll have a safety net.
Which speaks directly to that
core vision, right?
Healthcare education, childcare
support systems.
Exactly.
Providing universal, accessible
services, ensuring a baseline of
dignity and security for all
citizens.
But beyond that, and this is a
point Abraham really emphasizes,
you'll have dignity in domestic
work and products.
Dignity in domestic work?
What does that mean practically?
Well, it isn't just some vague
aspiration.
It points to a very tangible
revitalization of local
industries and manufacturing,
leading to more stable, maybe
higher quality, potentially
better paying jobs right here
within the country.
Instead of relying on overseas
production.
Right.
Instead of relying on external
production that often exploits
cheaper labor and maybe less
stringent regulations elsewhere,
imagine, he suggests, a return
to craftsmanship, to goods built
to last, fostering a sense of
pride in national production
again.
And crucially, from the funding
perspective.
From the fundamental funding
perspective, Abraham asserts,
you'll have revenue that doesn't
bleed workers or chase ghosts.
Back to the ghosts.
It circles back to that core
argument about the efficiency
and the inevitability of tariff
collection providing a stable,
reliable income stream for the
state without, he argues,
disproportionately burdening the
middle class through direct
taxation or attempting that
futile pursuit of taxing the
elusive, highly mobile wealth of
global billionaires.
So it's presented as a pathway
to a more resilient, more
self-sufficient, maybe more
materially responsible economy.
One that is truly capable, in
his view, of sustaining a broad
and comprehensive social welfare
state for its citizens.
That's the promise laid out.
And this brings us, really, to
Abraham's provocative final
judgement.
It encapsulates his entire
argument and serves as a pretty
challenging summation.
Yeah, he doesn't pull any
punches at the end.
No, he makes an ultimate,
uncompromising assertion.
In other words, terrorists are
the only way to build the high
service, low material society
socialists claim to want.
The only way still very
definitive.
It's a bold declaration
suggesting that without the
mechanism of tariffs, that
vision of a comprehensive
welfare state is just
economically unfeasible in
today's global landscape.
Especially, he stresses, given
the undeniable inherent
limitations of finite material
resources on our planet.
And then he follows this with
that really challenging
conclusion.
Aim squarely at those who
advocate for socialist policies
but reject tariffs.
Right, he says.
And the fact that they hate
tariffs just proves they're not
serious, they're performative.
Performative Ouch again.
Yeah, they're capitalists and
socialist drag, clinging to
their portfolios while they
scream about fairness.
That is a very sharp critique.
Extremely sharp, it implies that
the resistance to tariffs,
despite what he sees as their
logical appeal within his
framework, exposes a fundamental
hypocrisy, or at the very least,
a profound lack of true
commitment to the actual
economic mechanics required to
build the society they claim to
espouse.
So it's not just a policy
disagreement in his eyes, it's
almost a character assessment of
underlying motives and
priorities.
That seems to be the
implication.
The essay then succinctly
summarizes its core economic and
philosophical points, really
distilling them for maximum
impact.
Energy may one day be almost
free materials.
Never will terrorists
acknowledge that reality.
Accepting the limits they.
Slow the churn, fund the state,
and force us to value what we
own.
And the final sentence of
Abraham's essay really is hard,
leaving the reader with this
powerful critical indictment of
the current political discourse
around social programs and
funding.
What's the final line?
If American socialists were
real, they'd love tariffs.
But they're not, so they don't,
and that's why nothing changes.
Wow, OK, that really forces you
to confront the gap he sees
between stated desires and
practical willingness.
Absolutely.
So just to recap this deep dive,
we've thoroughly explored Chris
Abraham's truly compelling and
for many I'm sure, undoubtedly
controversial argument, the idea
that tariffs are not just a way,
but perhaps the only way to fund
a comprehensive social welfare
state in the modern era.
Right, He posits that
traditional taxation just falls
short because wealth is so
mobile globally, creating those
ghosts he talks about.
And he argues tariffs uniquely
address this by collecting
revenue right at the border, by
passing all those complex
offshore financial maneuvers.
And beyond just funding, Abraham
presents Terrace as this
necessary break on what he sees
as unsustainable infinite
consumption of finite materials.
While simultaneously encouraging
quality domestic production and
a more sustainable, resilient
economy, much like the examples
he drew from Germany.
It's a comprehensive vision
really, linking economic policy
directly to environmental
sustainability and societal
well-being.
It really is.
This deep dive certainly raises,
I think, an important question
for you to consider as you
reflect on these insights.
We've discussed if the funding
mechanism for really expansive
social services, like the
socialist utopia Abraham
describes, truly requires these
uncomfortable trade-offs.
You know, like higher consumer
prices for many goods and a
significant reduction in the
sheer volume and convenience of
cheap imports.
Are societies genuinely willing
to make those kinds of
sacrifices?
That's the core tension, isn't
it?
Or will the enduring, deeply
ingrained appeal of readily
available, inexpensive
consumption ultimately always
outweigh the desire for that
comprehensive social safety net?
We've seen how deeply entrenched
our current consumption habits
are, and Abraham's argument
really suggests this is the
central tension we face.
Yeah.
And as you ponder that, we
definitely encourage you to
consider your own relationship
with consumption.
You know what Are you truly
willing to trade for the kind of
society you envision?
What policies do you genuinely
advocate for, and how do they
line up with these economic
realities, these finite resource
constraints?
This deep dive should hopefully
give you unique, perhaps even
uncomfortable, but ultimately
vital ends through which to
examine these really complex,
intertwined issues of economics,
sustainability, and societal
aspiration.